the next story relates to incineration
so let me reset a little bit
um
we
talked last week
about this report
that trump white house staffers
regularly had to
tape back together
um
things that donald trump would rip up
we now have more news about this
trump white house white house staffers
frequently put important documents into
burn bags
and sent them to the pentagon
to be incinerated so you've got
conflicting teams you've got one team
that understands presidential records
act and preservation of records when
trump rips stuff up and tosses it they
run in and tape it back together
it's like you know reminded of the movie
a beautiful mind
some of you will get that reference and
then at the same time you've got another
team
that is
collecting records and sending them to
be incinerated
trump-era white house staffers
frequently put documents in burn bags
regular burn runs would see these bags
taken to the pentagon for incineration
this is for the washington post it was
up to the staffers to decide which
documents to preserve and which to
destroy
it has been widely reported that trump
had a penchant for tearing apart
presidential documents but details have
emerged about how aids disposed of
potentially important papers
burn bags resemble paper grocery bags
and are widely available at the white
house organizations dealing with top
secret info like the cia and nsa often
use them because destruction via burn
bags is considered superior to shredding
that's true you can sometimes tape
together stuff that's been shred
shredded uh you tip you want to use a
cross cut shredder instead of the one
that just generates strips but it's
crazy what the kids these days can do so
you burn it of course it appears that it
was done with documents that are
supposed to be preserved
this was a disaster it was almost a
comical fiasco the comical element being
trump eating notes and i told you about
this last week
back in 2018 was reported by newsweek
trump ate a document after cohen meeting
according to former white house aide
omarosa manigault newman she said she
walked in on trump eating paper after a
meeting with lawyer michael cohen
in what she believed was an effort to
destroy sensitive information
i saw him put a note in his mouth
since trump was
why is this story so funny even though
it's so insane since trump was ever the
germaphobe i was shocked he appeared to
be chewing
and swallowing the paper it must have
been something very very sensitive it is
genuinely insane
that the biggest issue of the 2016
election
that trump made about hillary was
document retention policies
and this was what donald trump was doing
his entire presidency and they still
have it in for hillary understand that
you know we we covered trump's rally
about
uh nine days ago
in conroe texas
at that rally he talked about hillary
clinton and the crowd starts chanting
locker up
understand that the origins of locker up
are over hillary's document and email
retention
concerns that donald trump made issue
number one during the 2016 election
they now know or they could know trump
was eating documents trump was ripping
up documents trump was burning documents
trump took documents home to mar-a-lago
and they still can't lock her up about
hillary who has never even been charged
uh never mind convicted of anything
related to that and his supporters will
applaud
they'll applaud lock her up and they'll
applaud trump's illegal activities where
he says well listen we had to we were
just trying to take the election back
from the guy who stole it or whatever
they cheer the corruption
and chant lock her up even though trump
did far worse when it came to records
um and retention of documents
and uh
handling proper handling of classified
and secret information they still can't
lock her up it's it is a backwards world
that we are living in my friends and the
idea that someday these folks will have
a realization like imagine trump runs in
2024
and we bring up whoever is the
democratic nominee i mean whoever just
brings up hey listen don't get scammed
again by this con man in 2016 he told
you hillary was the concern when it came
to records and trump ate documents
ripped documents
threw him out and had him burned
he is the con man he was the problem
don't fall for it again it's not going
to work with these people they they will
fall for whatever the 2024 talking point
is as willingly and as readily and as
quickly as they fell for it in 2016 and
that's why the concept of trump 2024
is so scary